З третьої спроби - Штайнмаєр зустрівся з Зеленським
Дев'ята зустріч - міністри енергетики країн ЄС
намагаються розв'язати питання щодо ціни на газ
Чотири вікна -
реставрація Собору Паризької Богоматері у Кельні
В ефірі «heute journal»
з Ґундулою Ґаузе та Анною Ґеллінек.
Добрий вечір.
Дорога до Києва мала багато перешкод,
тож дістатися туди вдалося лише з третьої спроби.
Президент Німеччини Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр
сьогодні здійснив візит до України
і нарешті зустрівся з Володимиром Зеленським.
Ще в середині квітня президентові відмовили у візиті,
пояснивши це тоді тим, що він не був бажаним гостем.
Підставою для дипломатичної образи
стала хибна, на думку України,
політика колишнього міністра
закордонних справ з партії SPD
Штайнмаєра щодо Росії.
Минулого четверга з міркувань безпеки
скасували й другу спробу візиту.
Опозиція почала глузувати з президента Німеччини,
вважаючи його боягузом.
Тож тепер - спроба №3.
Аннеґрет Остер розповість про подорож,
що відбулася ﻿зі значним запізненням,
та закінчилася примиренням.
Погляд президента Німеччини досить промовистий.
Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр прибув до Києва сьогодні
у другій половині дня.
Під час екскурсії мер столиці Віталій Кличко
показує йому понівечене місто.
Візит президента Німеччини до Києва
дуже важливий для нас, як і те,
що він на власні очі може побачити наслідки атак,
адже ми захищаємо не тільки наші місця,
ми відстоюємо ті ж цінності, що й Німеччина.
«Ми на вашому боці,
ви можете покластися на Німеччину,» -
саме це пообіцяв президент Німеччини.
Він вражений усім, що побачив вдень.
Наприкінці цього дня можу сказати,
що я дійсно щиро захоплююся
мужністю, незламністю, прагненням до свободи
та відвагою українців.
Штайнмаєр запропонував зміцнити сталий
партнерський зв'язок між країнами
через побратимство німецьких й українських міст
як «основу для практичного прояву солідарності».
Партнерства, про які я кажу,
не тільки допомагають у війні,
а й будують мости до нового спільного майбутнього,
коли, сподіваюся, мине війна.
Штайнмаєр відчув на собі,
що таке повсякденне життя в умовах війни,
під час візиту до містечка Корюківка,
що на північному сході від Києва.
Через повітряну тривогу президент Німеччину
був змушений піти в укриття.
Це дало нам особливо глибоке уявлення про умови,
в яких тут живуть люди.
Німеччина продовжуватиме допомагати -
таким є меседж дня.
Голуб миру є вираженням
чи не найбільшого бажання українців.
Україна не має часу.
Наближається зима, і ТЕЦ, лікарні та школи
потребують ремонту,
у чому Штайнмаєр зміг сьогодні переконатися особисто.
Важко оцінити, скільки все це коштуватиме,
враховуючи, що щодня є нові руйнування.
Тому на сьогоднішній конференції з питань
відновлення України в Берліні йшлося радше про те,
як, хто і що робить, ніж про те,
скільки грошей знадобиться для відбудови.
Перед тим, як ми поспілкуємося з українським
міністром, відповідальним за це питання,
Франк Бухвальд розповість із Берліна
про «план Маршалла 2.0».
Він привіз світлини з рідної країни.
Та те, що потім демонструє
прем'єр-міністр України Шмигаль,
спричиняє занепокоєння навіть у досвідчених політиків.
Кадри, які змушують відчути страждання,
спричинені російськими безпілотниками в Києві,
і те, наскільки терміново Україні потрібна допомога,
зокрема і для відбудови.
На Міжнародній конференції з питань відновлення
в Берліні йдеться про великі гроші.
350 млрд - у таку суму МВФ оцінює збитки від війни.
Україна говорить навіть про 750 млрд.
Кожний вкладений євро, долар, фунт, кожна єна -
це не просто допомога Україні, а й інвестиція
в демократичні цінності в усьому світі.
Йдеться про «план Маршалла» для України.
Допомога Києву - це підтримка майбутнього члена ЄС,
про це каже президент Зеленський,
який доєднався до конференції в телефонному режимі,
і розповідає, що його країна може зробити для Європи.
Україна виступає за європейську безпеку,
а не лише за безпеку наших сусідів.
ЄС також може з нашою допомогою
замістити російські енергоресурси.
Канцлер Шольц, який організував конференцію
як президент G7,
говорить про завдання поколінь
й обіцяє Києву довгострокову допомогу.
Відбудова сильної та успішної України -
це наше спільне завдання.
Я переконаний, що ми сильніші, коли ми єдині.
Ми об'єднані й будемо підтримувати Україну стільки,
скільки буде потрібно.
Це обіцянка, яка може надовго
зв'язати Німеччину і Європу.
Усі сторони мають великі надії.
З Берліна з нами на зв'язку
міністр розвитку громад та територій України
Олексій Чернишов.
Добрий вечір, пане Чернишов.
Ви відповідаєте за відбудову, особливо на Сході України,
тобто на територіях,
які Україна деокупувала.
Наскільки доцільно там щось відбудовувати?
Там досі тривають бойові дії, обстріли з боку Росії.
Добрий вечір, дякую.
Я хотів би почати з того, що є важливі області,
важливі території,
які Україна успішно повернула,
зокрема північні й східні регіони.
Це те, на чому ми зосереджені зараз
у контексті відбудови,
а також ми зосереджені на підготовці до зими.
А це - опалення та електроенергія для людей.
Східна Україна - не єдиний регіон, де це необхідно.
Ми бачимо, що росіяни здійснюють
посилені атаки з 10 жовтня.
Вони атакують енергетичну інфраструктуру,
і через це постраждало багато регіонів,
не тільки на сході, але й у центрі,
на заході й півдні.
Тому ми маємо відключення,
перебої в електропостачанні,
які ми просто зобов'язані усувати.
Саме тому ми говоримо про додаткову підтримку
щодо обладнання у сфері енергозабезпечення.
Отже, на цю мить йдеться не стільки про відбудову,
скільки про негайну допомогу на зиму,
яка наближається.
Що вам для цього необхідно?
На зиму, цілком зрозуміло, нам необхідно
забезпечити опалення.
Тому потрібна достатня кількість техніки
для енергозабезпечення, зокрема мобільні компоненти,
генератори, теплові станції,
теплові пункти та водоочисні споруди.
За останній час постраждало багато
об'єктів інфраструктури.
За останні два тижні понад 300 ракет і безпілотників
атакували територію України,
зокрема об'єкти енергопостачання.
Ремонт цих об'єктів - наш пріоритет.
Сьогоднішня конференція в Берліні
трохи зазирнула в майбутнє.
На ній ішлося про величезні суми, 350 млрд доларів,
750 млрд доларів, як у вигляді кредитів,
так і без подальшого відшкодування.
Ваші німецькі співрозмовники змогли Вам пояснити,
звідки ці гроші мають надійти?
Хочу сказати, що зараз дуже важлива оцінка
потреб і збитків, яка проводиться вперше.
Разом зі Світовим банком та Європейською комісією
ми проаналізували, що зараз пошкоджено.
Ми підрахували збитки на суму 349 млрд.
Це сума станом на 1 червня.
Сьогодні, звичайно, вона більша,
а наприкінці року буде переоцінка збитків.
Загальна відбудова розпочнеться,
звісно, після закінчення війни.
Але нам вже доводиться відновлювати
критичну інфраструктуру.
На цю мить її потрібно знову розбудувати
й відновити інфраструктуру в тих районах,
про які я згадував: на півночі
і на тих територіях,
які ми нещодавно звільнили від окупації.
Гаразд, очевидно, ви теж не знаєте, звідки візьмуться
гроші для фінансування.
Які гарантії Ви можете дати з української сторони?
До початку війни, бувши міністром,
ви теж боролися з корупцією
і закрили орган, який був схильний до неї.
Наскільки великою є проблема корупції
у Вашій країні зараз?
Очевидно, що відновлення потребує великих коштів.
На певному етапі йдеться вже про
сотні мільярдів євро, тож важливо,
щоб Україна зазнала реформ і мала можливість
імплементувати стратегічні реформи,
спрямовані на утвердження верховенства права,
правосуддя та боротьбу з корупцією.
Ми вже маємо значний досвід.
Ви також згадували про структуру з видачі ліцензій
на будівництво, яку ми нещодавно закрили.
Уряд України налаштований дуже серйозно,
ми щиро прагнемо втілити усі зазначені реформи.
Ви абсолютно маєте рацію,
наступні кроки до ЄС потребують значного прогресу
в реформаційній діяльності,
зокрема йдеться про особливо нагальні реформи.
Відповідно, втілення «плану Маршалла» теж залежатиме
від успіху цих реформ.
Щиро дякуємо. З нами на зв'язку з Берліна
був Олексій Чернишов.
Дякую.
Розмову з паном міністром
було записано сьогодні увечері.
А я передаю слово Ґундулі.
Далі говоритимемо про наведення політичного
ладу у Великій Британії.
Новообраний прем'єр-міністр
Великої Британії Ріші Сунак
оголосив про ухвалення непростих рішень
задля подолання проблем,
які накопичилися за останній час.
Він зазначив, що помилки необхідно виправляти,
а пріоритетом назвав економічну стабільність.
Уже ввечері Сунак почав формувати
новий кабінет міністрів.
Представниця правого крила партії Суелла Браверман
неочікувано зберегла свою посаду
міністерки внутрішніх справ.
Вона виступає за надзвичайно
жорстку міграційну політику.
Король ЧарльзIII офіційно схвалив кандидатуру
42-річного Ріші Сунака.
Тепер Сунаку належить сформувати уряд.
Нова прем'єр-міністерка Італії Джорджа Мелоні
у своїй першій промові перед урядом
оголосила про намір провадження
націоналістичної політики.
Лідерка ультраправої партії Брати Італії
повідомила про це під час
виступу в римському парламенті.
Також у промові Мелоні закликала
до змін в угодах із ЄС,
які виявилися неефективними, зокрема, йшлося про
реформування Пактупро стабільність і зростання.
Мелоні прагне подолати проблему нелегальної міграції.
Відтепер у Північноафриканському центрі для біженців
мають ретельніше перевіряти,
хто має право на притулок.
Федеральний конституційний суд Німеччини
почав розгляд позову AfD.
Партія вимагає збільшення державних субсидій
для свого фонду «Desiderius Erasmus Stiftung»,
а також неупередженого ставлення.
Річ у тім, що фонди, наближені до інших партій,
отримують державне фінансування,
загалом близько 660 млн євро на рік,
попри те, що для цього наразі не існує
жодних правових підстав.
Судді розглянуть дотримання принципу вірності
конституції політичними фондами,
яке у випадку наближеного до AfD фонду було
поставлене під сумнів іншими фракціями.
Вирок суду очікують вже в наступному році.
Перейдімо до новин Близького Сходу: минулої ночі
ізраїльські солдати обстріляли
місто Наблус на Західному березі річки Йордан,
штурмуючи штаб-квартиру одного з
незаконних збройних формувань.
П'ять громадян Палестини загинуло,
серед них і лідер дедалі впливовішого
угруповання «Лігво лева»,
до якого приєднується все більше палестинської
молоді в Наблусі,
розчарувавшись у тривалих конфліктах з Ізраїлем.
Унаслідок зіткнення щонайменше
20 людей отримали поранення.
Обмеження ціни на газ: усі про нього говорять,
однак ніхто насправді не знає,
як воно працює, якщо працює взагалі.
Сенс дуже простий: якщо газ стає занадто дорогим,
втручається держава та знижує його вартість.
В ідеалі на цей крок мають піти всі країни ЄС.
Але чи згодяться на таку ціну постачальники?
«Так,» - кажуть жителі Південної Європи,
які прагнуть збути газ.
Німеччина ж та інші країни Північної Європи, які гостро
відчувають потребу в електроносіях,
не дають ствердної відповіді,
адже, зважаючи на попит, постачальники
можуть встановлювати будь-яку ціну.
Про це Європа продовжувала
дискутувати минулого тижня на саміті ЄС,
сьогодні ж дискусії продовжилися між
міністрами енергетики.
Обмеження ціни на газ залишається фантомним.
Далі - репортаж Флоріана Нойгана з Люксембургу.
На цю тему існує гарна англійська приказка:
«kick the can down the road» -
штовхати банку далі дорогою.
Саме це і закидають Німеччині.
У Люксембурзі відбулося чергове
засідання міністрів енергетики,
вже вдев'яте з початку війни.
Головне питання зустрічі не змінилося:
Як боротися з високими цінами на енергоносії?
Чи допоможе обмеження ціни на газ?
Німецький уряд не вважає це рішення ефективним,
саме тому і зволікав довгі місяці.
Але терпець вривається.
Ми просто маємо знизити
ціну на газ, яку сплачують громадяни Європи,
а також наші підприємства.
Це питання варто розв'язати терміново.
Наближається зима.
Звісно, багато країн хвилює,
чи вплине ціна на газ на вартість електроенергії.
Після саміту ЄС, що відбувся минулого
тижня, обмеження ціни на газ отримало нову назву:
«динамічний ціновий коридор».
Однак у нього все ж є великий недолік:
усі розуміють це поняття по-різному.
Деякі країни, зокрема Німеччина, вважають
ціновий коридор валідним
для боротьби з можливими абсолютно
невиправданими спекуляціями.
Інші ж налаштовані скептично:
чи потрібен цей коридор узагалі?
Це хороше запитання.
Можливо, варто поговорити й про мінімальну ціну
в такому контексті?
Мабуть, до цього справа все ж не дійде.
Насправді ж ціни на газ на міжнародному ринку
останні кілька тижнів падають.
З піку в серпні й до сьогодні ціна досягла свого
мінімуму - менш як 100 євро за мегават-годину газу.
На цей графік неодноразово покликався
у своєму виступі в Люксембурзі віцеканцлер Габек.
Сьогодні зранку ціна на газ вкотре суттєво впала.
Це результат політичних заходів, які ми вживали
упродовж останніх тижнів і місяців.
Отже, головний меседж, який намагався донести
до громадськості Габек, -
ми взяли ситуацію під контроль, ціни падають.
Але є один нюанс:
як кажуть експерти, головним фактором, що посприяв
несподіваному падінню цін стала... погода.
Цьогорічна осінь у Європі напрочуд тепла.
Водночас ціни за постачання природного газу
наступного року стануть ще вищими.
Отже, ціна все ще залишиться на рівні 140 євро
за мегават-годину, що приблизно в сім разів більше,
ніж у докризовий період.
Тобто незначне падіння цін, яке ми можемо зараз
спостерігати, на жаль, не означає,
що в наступному році ситуація поліпшиться.
Принаймні в чомусь міністри сьогодні одностайні:
в майбутньому Європа збільшить спільні закупівлі газу.
Подальші обговорення заплановано на наступне,
десяте засідання після початку війни,
що відбудеться вже за чотири тижні.
Хто знає, наскільки затягнуться переговори щодо
встановлення обмеження ціни на газ.
Придбання Китаєм акцій контейнерного
терміналу в порту Гамбурга -
розумне економічне рішення
чи безвідповідальний ризик?
У німецькому уряді точаться дискусії.
Канцлер Шольц підтримав капіталовкладення
китайської державної компанії COSCO,
шість міністрів висловилися проти.
Однак, здається, Олаф Шольц твердо налаштований
все ж укласти угоду з COSCO.
Компромісним рішенням стало зменшення
залучення китайських співробітників із 35% до 24,9%.
Що це змінює і чи покладе це рішення край суперечкам -
знає Ральф Ціммерман.
Порт розташований безпосередньо
поруч із центром міста.
Це Tollerort - найменший з чотирьох
контейнерних терміналів Гамбурга.
Китайці постачають до міста та прилеглих населених
пунктів товари з Далекого Сходу ще з 1980-х років.
Однак їм ніколи не дозволяли брати участь в
управлінні подібними перевезеннями в Гамбурзі.
Ми також помітили, що під час великих криз,
які ми вдосталь спостерігали в останні роки, зокрема
фінансова криза 2009 року, криза коронавірусу,
судноплавні компанії оминали Гамбурзький порт,
оскільки не брали безпосередньої участі
в роботі терміналів.
Здебільшого компанії використовують на повну
потужність ті термінали, акціями яких вони володіють.
Це означає, що порт Гамбург втратив у кризові роки
більше вантажних перевезень, ніж його конкуренти.
Запеклі суперечки про компромісне рішення
продовжилися і сьогодні,
після того, як попередньо схвалені
відомством канцлера 35% акцій
китайської державної судноплавної компанії COSCO
було вирішено зменшити до 24,9%.
Сьогодні ми як ніколи чітко усвідомлюємо
свою залежність від таких держав, як Росія і Китай.
Тому Німеччина має прокинутися,
Європа має прокинутися.
Це ж я можу сказати й жителям Гамбурга,
хоча йдеться не лише про це місто.
Йдеться про незалежність Німеччини і Європи в цілому.
У Берліні, де сьогодні «світлофорна» коаліція
залаштунково ухвалила компромісне рішення,
коаліція наполегливо протестувала проти подальшого
залучення Китаю в економіку країни.
Продаж газових сховищ Росії створив можливості
для шантажу Німеччини.
Самовпевненість стане основою для нових криз.
Ми не можемо дозволити, щоб подібне сталося
після угоди з Китаєм.
У Гамбурзі сьогодні також клопотали про те,
щоб звести до мінімуму обговорення подібних питань
і вивести план участі Китаю з тіні
загальних стратегічних дебатів.
Йдеться не про продаж інфраструктури,
не про продаж порту Гамбурга,
а про міноритарний пакет акцій
операційної компанії Tollerort.
Це забезпечить робочі місця
та гарантуватиме завантаженість Гамбурзького порту.
Чи буде досягнуто наміченого компромісу
і чи ухвалить це рішення уряд  -
це питання лишається відкритим.
Як і те, як Німеччина реагуватиме на подібні
стратегічні інвестиції з боку Китаю в майбутньому.
Новини економіки розповість Ґундула.
Робоча група з податкових розрахунків розпочала
обговорювати питання розвитку податкових надходжень.
Очевидно, що Німеччина, її землі та громади
можуть розраховувати на вищі доходи
до 2026 року, а саме приблизно на 110 млрд євро
більше, ніж передбачалося раніше.
Про це повідомляє видання «Handelsblatt».
Рушієм податкових надходжень є висока інфляція,
яка своєю чергою загрожує Німеччині рецесією
в умовах енергетичної кризи.
Про це знову попереджає Мюнхенський інститут
економічних досліджень Ifo
у своєму актуальному індексі бізнес-клімату.
Компанії налаштовані негативно.
Стефані Барретт розповість більше.
Так, це правда, але все ж не настільки,
як усі цього побоювалися.
Щодо перспектив:
завжди можна побачити світло в кінці тунелю.
9000 опитаних компаній оцінили актуальну ситуацію
як надзвичайно складну, що й не дивно:
зрештою, зимова рецесія не за горами,
тобто комплексний, тривалий спад економічного
виробництва, яке передусім вдарить по енергомістких
галузях промисловості, зокрема скляній,
хімічній та паперовій.
2/3 підприємств все ще страждають
від проблем з постачанням.
Проблемною залишається роздрібна торгівля:
експерти побоюються, що через високі ціни покупці
просто залишаться вдома, і будівельна галузь, яка
раніше мала неабиякий попит, втратить усі
замовлення, зокрема, через зростання вартості
матеріалів і підвищення відсоткових ставок.
Лише постачальники послуг більш
оптимістично налаштовані щодо найближчих місяців.
Багато компаній, однак, покладають надії на допомогу
сумою 200 млрд і обмеження цін на енергоносії.
Наповнені газосховища також зменшують ризик
критичного дефіциту газу.
Помірні жовтневі температури та послаблення
на ринках електроенергії та газу
значно покращують настрої на біржових торгах.
Індекс Dax зростає майже на один відсоток
і долає позначку в 13 тис. пунктів.
Це показники біржі на Волл-стріт,
яка, як відомо, задає тенденції.
Подивимось, як довго протримається ця тенденція.
Дякую, з нами на зв'язку була
Стефані Баррет з Франкфурта.
Виробник спортивних товарів Adidas
припинив співпрацю з репером Каньє Вестом.
Причиною стали численні словесні випади
та антисемітські
висловлювання американського репера
у соцмережах Instagram і Twitter.
Одяг та взуття, розроблені Вестом,
приносять Adidas 1,5 млрд євро,
що ставить близько 7% річного обігу.
Раптове припинення продажу
та виробництва цих моделей
може негативно позначитися на фінансових показниках
відомого на весь світ німецького підприємства.
Молодіжне слово року - «smash».
Найчастіше воно вживається як дієслово.
У німецькій мові «smashen»
означає «почати з кимось щось робити»,
«когось підчепити» або навіть більше.
Водночас це слово також може означати «побачення».
За результатами журі видавництва «Langenscheidt»,
на другому місці опинилося слово
«bodenlos» («неймовірно» в негативному значенні),
а на третьому - «Macher» («творець»).
Сьогодні у всьому світі люди виходили на вулиці,
щоб побачити часткове сонячне затемнення.
Місяць частково перекрив сонячний диск,
це тривало приблизно дві години,
а потім видовище в Центральній Європі закінчилося.
Це явище привернуло увагу людей
також в інших країнах.
Тим, хто пропустив сьогоднішнє затемнення,
доведеться запастися терпінням,
адже наступне відбудеться у жовтні 2025.
Три з половиною роки тому ці кадри шокували весь світ.
Пожежа у Соборі Паризької Богоматері, внесеного
до списку світової культурної спадщини ЮНЕСКО.
Дах був майже повністю зруйнований,
шпиль завалився.
За 400 кілометрів на північний схід від Парижа,
мешканці німецького міста Кельн
як ніхто інший розуміють значення такого собору.
Жителі міста та всього Північного Рейну-Вестфалії
негайно розпочали збір коштів,
а місцева організація з відновлення соборів
запропонувала конкретну допомогу:
реставрацію особливої частини
Собору Паризької Богоматері.
До речі, єдиної, яку реставрують за кордоном.
Репортаж з Кельна Ральфа Ґольдмана.
Коли горів Собор Паризької Богоматері,
Елоді Шнайдер якраз проходила стажування
в майстерні кельнської
організації з відновлення соборів.
29-річна француженка – реставраторка скла,
свою професію здобула в Ельзасі.
Коли стало зрозуміло, що чотири вітражі
з Собору Паризької Богоматері
реставруватимуть у Кельні,
вона без вагань залишилась тут.
Зараз вона очищає скло, відновлює фрагменти
та свинцевий каркас.
Ми з'єднуємо маленькі фрагменти вітража
за допомогою клею та силікону,
зараз додаю свинець, щоб все добре трималося.
Це трохи схоже на пазл.
Собор Паризької Богоматері
запалав 15 квітня 2019 року.
Тоді впав шпиль собору.
Жар, дим, кіптява та вода для гасіння
пошкодили значну його частину.
Тоді архітектор з Кельна Петер Фюссеніх
сидів зі сльозами на очах перед телевізором.
Під час пожежі в Соборі Паризької Богоматері
згоріли не лише дерев'яні балки собору,
а й надбання поколінь,
секрети собору,
оригінальні деталі з 13-го століття.
Вітражі собору створили 1965 року.
Це роботи французького
художника Жака ле Шевальє.
Так вони виглядали до пожежі.
Кожний вітраж має розмір приблизно 30 м².
З весни чотири вітража перебувають у Кельні.
Кожний з них складається
з майже 80 окремих фрагментів.
У майстерні їх спочатку ретельно очищають
і старанно звільняють від свинцю.
Експерти створили спеціальну камеру
для захисту від пилу.
Після цього кожен фрагмент сфотографували та
занесли до каталогу.
Потім ми перейшли до
практичної частини тут, у майстерні:
стабілізації свинцю, з'єднання фрагментів вітража,
стабілізації фрагментів,
які виявились пошкодженими під шаром свинцю.
Роботи з відновлення стали можливими завдяки
благодійній акції у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії
з залученням ЮНЕСКО,
під час якої зібрали півмільйона євро.
Роботи мають завершити до 15 квітня 2024 року.
Рівно за п'ять років після пожежі
Собор Паризької Богоматері
має знову засяяти, як раніше.
Це жорсткий реченець для майстерні.
Ми маємо відновити всі вітражі,
фрагмент за фрагментом,
а потім знову встановити всі їх наново
у Соборі Паризької Богоматері.
Там хоче бути й Елоді Шнайдер.
Команда з Кельна планує особисто
привезти вікна до Парижа,
а також допомогти з їх встановленням.
А до того часу їм тут ще залишається багато роботи.
На цьому ми завершуємо свою частину випуску.
А зараз рекомендуємо репортаж із програми «37 Grad».
Тема: катастрофічна нестача
вчителів у німецьких школах
і як спеціалісти з інших галузей намагаються
заповнити ці прогалини.
А о 00.30 Крістіна фон Унґерн-Штернберґ
зустрінеться з вами у випуску «heute journal update».
Ми повернемося завтра, до побачення.
Добрий вечір і ласкаво просимо до огляду погоди.
З настанням тепла останній день літа
дедалі зміщується.
Тож цього тижня маємо 25°C і навіть дещо вище.
За такою температурою зазвичай
визначають саме літній день.
Така спека вже панує
на Півдні Європи, тут фіксують приблизно 30°C.
Це тепло підхоплює циклон в Атлантичному океані,
який прямує з Іспанії через Францію в Німеччину.
Вам відома ця погодна ситуація ще з літа.
Вона вже неодноразово виникала
під час спеки, і тепер також.
Що ж буде вночі?
На південному заході пройдуть невеликі дощі,
які поступово переміщуватимуться на північний схід.
На сході буде сухо, біля водойм
подекуди утворюватиметься туман.
У південно-західних регіонах Німеччини
температура знизиться до 13°C.
та до 4°C на Північнонімецькій низовині.
Завтра вранці дощ збережеться, особливо на півдні.
Так він буде несильним.
На півночі буде сонячно ближче до вечора.
Згодом на південному заході.
дощ закінчиться.
Частково збережеться невелика хмарність,
але залишиться сухо.
Температура сягатиме 23°C на південному заході
та 14°C на південному сході.
У наступні кілька днів буде ще тепліше,
температура сягатиме 24°C у четвер
та 26°C у п'ятницю.
Бажаю гарного вечора.